today's session started with tributes to
those caught up in the English Channel
migrant tragedy
Mr Speaker I'm sure the whole house will
share my sorrow at the capsizing of a
small boat in the channel in the early
hours of this morning and the tragic
loss of human life it's a reminder that
the criminal gangs running those routes
put the lives of the desperate at risk
and profit from their misery they must
be broken up and brought to Justice
tomorrow members of the Royal College of
Nursing will go on strike for the first
time in their history so today kirst
armor chose to focus on that industrial
action and attempted to argue it's the
government's fault for not negotiating
all the prime minister has to do to stop
that is to open the door and discuss pay
with them after 12 years of Tory failure
winter has arrived for our public
services and we've got a prime minister
who has curled up in a ball and gone
into hibernation
's team believe that because strikes are
so widespread because voters know life
is tough and the cost of living is real
there is an instinctive resonance with
the plight of Strikers in contrast to
Richie sunax allies argue that secure is
yet again ignoring reality to score
political points The Honorable gentleman
says to get round the table but we all
know what that means Mr Speaker that is
just simply a political formula for
avoiding taking a position on this issue
issue pay demands of 19 are met then he
should say so and it all soon descended
into familiar and not entirely relevant
territory
she's too weak to stand up for tax
avoiders he's not strong enough to stand
up to the union but as usual Mr Speaker
he tries to blame everyone else if we'd
listened to him Mr Speaker the backlog
would still be growing and that's
because we'd still be in lockdown
kierstama's final question of the final
pmqs this year focused on a point of
policy agreement the war in Ukraine
Millions will spend Christmas in
Sub-Zero temperatures without heating
electricity or hot water
their suffering is unimaginable but
their bravery is awe-inspiring this
Christmas many families will be laying
an extra place at their Christmas table
and that speaks to the generosity and
compassion of our nation and long may
that continue throughout today's
questions there was a festive feel but
with a distinctly Bleak Outlook ordinary
families are facing a dickensian
nightmare across the country this
Christmas we know it's Christmas but the
party's not started yeah this year the
Tory party has given us five education
secretaries four chancellors three prime
ministers two leadership
[Applause]
and the and Mr Speaker The Partridge
just have to sell the pear tree to pay
the gas
[Laughter]
after yet another year old political
Perma crisis MPS seem desperate for
their Christmas break pmqs is back in
four weeks time and all the same
challenges the war in Ukraine the NHS
public sector pay seemed sure to feature
again